I'm judging by what the Prime Minister
has been writing for the papers this
morning she sees this week as a
validation of her brexit strategy she
has in her words at proving the doubters
wrong in what possible way can that be
true oh I think a couple of things I
think the Prime Minister has shown that
she can get the deal for the United
Kingdom there were many people who
leading up to the agreement was finally
signed off by the council on Friday
saying that even that wasn't going to
happen wasn't possible and she managed
to do that and by being very focused on
it determined about it we've got a good
deal for the EU citizens here in the UK
the right deal for British citizens is
over million British citizens working
and living abroad in Europe as well as
getting a package that shows we can move
on importantly to that next step
getting the trade negotiations going and
the implementation period you're
absolutely right there were plenty of
people who doubted that we would get to
this point the problem is the question
is at what cost have we moved on to face
- I mean even in the agreements that
have been reached there have been a
number of missteps may take phase one
last week on this program and elsewhere
we were told by the press secretary the
Northern Ireland secretary that this was
yet a framework a Memorandum of
Understanding you know the EU and the
Irish government through the toys over
the pram and know we discover it's to be
legally binding well we've said there'll
be a withdraw bill that would go through
Parlin probably the back end of 2018 and
that's also important because that's
partly what also gives that certainty to
the EU citizens living here in the UK
about the set of states we're going to
go up there and that's good for business
business has certainty that the staff
and the people we've got here contribute
to our economy know that they can stay
in businesses know they can stay so I
think it is an important part of what
we're doing and as we've said from the
very beginning these are about
negotiations and negotiations mean that
you have to look at these things as you
go forward but how do you reconcile the
notion that what we've agreed on phase 1
as regards to EU citizens rights as
regard to the Irish border so on
how do you reconcile their idea that
that is no leak or soon to be legally
binding upon us with the idea contained
in the text that nothing is agreed until
everything is agreed
well actually got to judge us by what we
said and what we actually do for example
with citizens rights not only we're
going to be putting that into
legislation with that withdrawal piece
of legislation later in 2018 in the
second half of 2018 we will start the
process of giving set of status we'll
have that live as a voluntary scheme in
that second half of 2018 before we've
left so
they clearly indicating our
determination to deliver and do the
right thing as we said from the very
beginning fulfill our moral duty as much
as anything else but it's been a
complete fudge on the issue of the
Northern Ireland Ireland border isn't it
no not at all we've said from the again
for the very beginning we are going to
make sure that we respect not just the
Good Friday Agreement but the common
travel area which goes beyond Ireland
obviously but what we do in terms of the
negotiations the trade agreement is
important and that comes in the next
stage you've made promises to the DUP
you've made promises to the Irish
government one site has to be
disappointed by whatever solution you
come up with well actually the reason I
think the trees are made so perfect to
be taking these negotiations is she's
shown she's somebody who can bring
everybody together she's done that
within the country she's delivering what
we're doing she's certainly done it
within our party where we have people on
both sides of that referendum and I
think she can do that on the more wider
negotiations including in Northern
Ireland to get to an agreement so what
negotiations are all about the worse for
everybody well what you've got is a form
of words that both the DUP and the Irish
government can can put up with no
actually as regards I mean that the
board are there I mean any solution
potentially leaves you as immigration
minister with something of a hair day
you know with a porous border with
people able to travel and goods able to
move freely across it and how do you
keep any grip on immigration well we
have safe in the very beginning we want
to make sure that there is a
frictionless border there we're not
going to have a hard border in northern
that is important but how to say
immigration and our work immigration
goes beyond the fact we have a lot of
intelligence advanced information we
also have that compliant environment
that we're breathing for the ordinary
use citizens who'd be free to travel to
the Republic of Ireland what would stop
them from being free to travel to to
Northern Ireland but of course they'll
be able to carry on traveling through
with a registration scheme through that
implementation period what we're going
to do in phase 3 will obviously follow
and we publish our immigration be on our
white paper pretty soon actually they
bill will be early next year and we're
ready to see the feedback for the
migration Advisory Committee that
independent group of experts who going
to you must have an idea of a solution
that I mean you're talking very
confidently about the fact that there
won't be a back door to entry into the
United Kingdom so how do we plug that
gap well two things firstly as tempting
as it is to go into detail before we
publish the white paper I'm gonna have
to ask you to just be a bit a bit
patient just yet Christmas isn't quite
upon us yes there's still time but also
to be very clear immigration controls go
well beyond that so
the work we're doing on the compliant
environment whites are work that whites
arendt the work with bank accounts and
drive-in licenses all that means that
people are coming here legally will be
able to prosper and contribute people
who are here illegally will find it
harder to be able to go forward a
clearly immigration was was the central
issue of the EU referendum and the
longer that we have discussions like
this without any proper defined solution
at being described to people who voted
to leave the European Union you can
understand why people are starting to
get a little bit nervous
do you still believe that a net
migration target of tens of thousands is
possible I do think we can getting it to
migration down to those sustainable
levels and the reason I think that is
actually the evidence of what we saw in
just the last roughly 10 days ago the
latest setting at migration figures
which showed the biggest fall we've seen
on record down by a hundred and six
thousand it weren't even six figures but
within that what's important is the
people coming here for confirmed jobs
was up the people come here is
entrepreneurs and investors students all
of those were up and a record number of
passenger visitors so shows that we're
delivering what business needs whilst
getting control of our borders and
that's something I think you're
absolutely right about people want to
see us get control of our borders but
that it's going to be free movement four
years after march 29 one the free
unfettered movement brexit to a lot of
people who simply not mean brexit well
when we get to March 2019 that legal
entity of freedom of movements we know
it will end we will then move into
system of people but we'll be able to
move fluidly across from Europe but
it'll be a registration scheme which is
an important part of the changes to need
to our future immigration system that
will come in after the implementation
period but in essence hasn't Philip
Hammond yesterday in China not
essentially said actually it's status
call until the point at which we have
that that final deal struck it's not the
point at which we come out of the
European Union that things will change
significantly is it well look what we've
been very clear about is we want to make
sure there's no cliff edge the business
has access to the skills he needs their
economy can continue to flourish and one
of these that's very clear when I talk
to people who have felt very strongly
about leaving the European Union I
represent an area that voters over
seventy two percent is they want to know
that that control is coming back it is
we're going to do in an orderly way in a
smooth way and that's why that
implementation period is so important
but but March 2019 is for so many of
Tudor mcdhh attit is the point of which
we are no longer part of the European
Union however after that point we don't
still have to you know adhere to their
rules or we operate under the joke do
diction of the ECG we've also got to
accept any new rules that the EU imposes
upon us in what way is that brexit well
a couple of key points with that firstly
obviously will be out of those
institutions technically won't be a
memory will be a real ticker but you'll
have any influence we haven't yet
completed the negotiations around what
that phase to implementation pier will
be so let's not preempted that so people
pre-empting what would happen in the
first round and then the Prime Minister
proved them wrong and delivered but also
we've got to make sure we do what's
right for the British economy and within
that we will do that in terms of as I
said immigration will be different there
will be a registration scheme which is
part of moving forward to our final
phase three position which will go
public with inflation X on what you've
just said you think that people like
Jacob Riis mark who suggests that we
will be a vassal state of the European
Union you think that he doesn't have the
Brit Britain's economic interest I know
I'm saying something quite different
what I'm saying is I think the Prime
Minister the work that we will be doing
is a gun would deliver to make sure that
people with its Jacob Riis MOG or
anybody else on either side of the
debate can see that we come up with a
deal that's good for the United Kingdom
and let's be honest be very clear the
way that Europe works most of the walls
that are coming in over this companies
rules that have been developed now while
we are part of that process and we are
contributing to it
just in terms of the withdrawal bill the
EU withdraw built I mean does that sig
does the defeat this weak signal once
and for all that you don't have a
working majority well we've got a very
small majority in the House Commons
that's a mathematical fact it's one of
the things that came out at the general
election what it does also show is
actually we're making sure we deliver
because obviously we're the very early
stages of this bill we are delivering
bricks it we will believe in the
European Union the vast majority of
things when we were told there be lots
and lots of folks lost at this we have
lost one vote but everything else has
gone through and what we're doing is
look at the results of that vote to make
sure we can go forward and do what we
can to deliver a unified position
actually where we can across Parliament
how do you feel when you see colleagues
if yours perhaps even friends of youit's
being described as traitors it being
suggested that they should face
deselection because they voted against
the whip I wouldn't describe any
colleague in that way and I think some
of the attacks we see on him he's
generally very much covered today I
think and welcomed and unnecessary mon
life actually particularly in Parliament
with those I know and I've handled a
bill myself which has had people on it
on a different side to me and verbals in
our own party and they do that because
they feel very strongly about
something that's what Parliament is
about our job as the government is to
work with that listen to that as we have
been listening all the way through to
look at how we can make sure we deliver
something that works for everyone
but what do you make though of you know
papers write the Daily Mail to a lesser
extent the telegraph clearly identifying
those who voted with their conscience
admittedly against the whip as as
traitors well I think we have a free
press in this country and different
parts the press kind of different views
about these things for me personally
these are colleagues they feel
passionate about these things they've
made a strong case about something they
managed to convince enough people in
Parliament to vote that way we've got to
make sure that we're listening to that
we respect the fact that they had these
strong views but ultimately it doesn't
change that core thing which is that we
will be leaving the European Union we've
all got to be very clear about the
public did vote we had a referent and we
have to respect that Democratic decision
still how is how is losing a vote on the
EU withdrawal bill how is that proving
the doubters wrong in the Prime
Minister's works well what the Prime
Minister's done is deliver that first
stage of the agreement got us onto stage
to something many doubters felt wasn't
possible she's delivered on that and
actually even with the bill that's going
through Parliament I'm at the moment the
core work in that to make sure that we
leave the European Union that we do it
on the date that we set out in article
50 all of that are things we're
delivering on and obviously the bill is
that is early stages we're not even
finished it in the Commons let alone in
the Lord's yet Minister many thanks and
there are many Christmas when it comes
you to and all do everybody watching in
the heat